and it's an amazing ascension for the 37
year old brandon staley i'm looking at
his history you mentioned the connection
to fangio he was with fangio 2019
in denver as the outside linebackers
coach two years before that in chicago
with fangio when vic was the defensive
coordinator and staley was the outside
linebacker's coach
prior to that he was the defensive
coordinator at john
carroll university nothing against john
carroll university
but from john carroll university the
chicago bears is one hell of a bump
and it's amazing you see this in the
backgrounds of a lot of coaches that
progression where all of a sudden it's
like how the hell did that happen
and talk about what a difference one
break can make for a guy and there's so
many coaches out there
they're just kind of churning in
anonymity anonymity i sound like sins
anonymity
anonymity at these at these lower level
colleges
and all of a sudden it pops they get a
break they're in the right place at the
right time whatever the case may be
and it's this meteoric rise it's really
stunning to see when you
when you look at the list of jobs where
all of a sudden something doesn't make
sense
here and now this guy's on track to be
an nfl head coach
you know the amazing thing is you know
and i know staley a little bit i don't
know him well mike but the amazing thing
is
that you know three weeks ago the
los angeles rams went to tampa and
this was a big deal for for uh staley
because
he's he's a big football fan he loves
football one of the reasons why mcvay
loves staley is because he loves
football
and i think one of the things that
staley
had so much respect for when he looked
at the schedule this year
you know basically three weeks apart he
was going to be able to play tom brady
one week and bill belichick the next
week and uh you know the next
you know three weeks later and you know
he went to
they went to tampa and although the you
know the score was close
he really frustrated tom brady that
night for much of that game
and then obviously last night you know
holding the new england patriots to
three points
i i thought it was just really an
embarrassing game for cam newton and i
don't know
where this leaves the patriots in their
quarterback situation
those two games right there one against
bruce aryan tom brady won against bill
belichick
josh mcdaniels essentially uh
are is going to make him if not uh
bound for a job at least a candidate for
a job
come january 4th yeah and look we've
seen it time and again you never know
what a coordinator gonna do when he
finally gets a chance to become a head
coach it's a different skill set
sometimes guys grow into the job
sometimes they don't but given
the manner in which staley has adapted
quickly and successfully to the nfl
someone is going to seriously consider
him to be a head coach coming up here in
the not too distant future
we are firm though in the window where
the candidates outnumber the jobs and
the people who
have the buzz attached to them are more
plentiful than the opportunities will be
and we're awaiting in just about three
weeks and two days the
commencement of the annual game of
musical chairs to see who lands where
and who gets what job
and the rams on track
for a division championship now peter at
nine and four
he won't be available let's stay in the
same division
staley and robert sala salah by all
appearances is going to be available to
be hired right out of the gates unlike
last year when he wasn't available until
after the super bowl
and and i know that that you've
complained about this and advocated for
change
i have others have it something's wrong
with this picture these jobs are too
scarce the window opens too infrequently
for candidates
to be slowed down by the rule that says
thou shalt not hire someone until
their team season is over
yeah i mean it's just a mistake and
i it's not only unfair to the candidates
i really think it's unfair to the teams
because mike i can tell you this right
now
i can't tell you who the who the
candidate was but two years ago
there was a candidate who his team
wanted who a
team wanted to hire and afterwards
one of the factors when this person was
not hired
by this team one of the factors was
that the person running the search
for the hiring team just said you know
we
really thought that it was close and we
might
have liked the other guy better but it
was very close
and we just decided we would rather get
potentially
a three or four week head start you know
depending on how long the other
team was in the playoffs and so that is
the thing and look
you know ironically somebody else could
say well peter you know we
look this actually helped the
indianapolis colts didn't it
because when by the time josh mcdaniels
told them
no in 2018 all the field
was uh you know was pillaged it was gone
so they had to go to the number five or
six guy on the original list
that chris ballard the gm of the colts
had that was frank wright
and i can just tell you this right now
they're living happily ever after in
indianapolis
and i think they're really happy the way
that turned out but
it just to me it's not fair to the teams
and it's certainly not fair to the
candidates
that some people will not be candidates
because their teams are still in the uh
in the playoffs on january 4th
but the right situation to me just
proves how
many qualified candidates there are
to become nfl head coaches and how many
people
can do the job at a high level if given
the opportunity
there just aren't the opportunities and
the playoff birth
the playoff success keeping certain
coaches from being available
for josh mcdaniels it's probably not
going to be an issue for him this year
either if he's considering making the
jump although
the shine for him not like it's been in
past years because the patriots now
six and seven peter and by all
appearances
not headed for the postseason
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports